en la madrugada del jueves Más de 200
soldados israelíes asaltaron la ciudad
vieja de nablus matando a tres
palestinos e hiriendo a varios más dos
de los abatidos eran militantes buscados
acusados de matar a una mujer británico
israelí y a dos de sus hijas el mes
pasado
una vez que el ejército israelí se
retiró volvió a casa Solo para
encontrarla completamente destruida las
tuberías de agua habían explotado subió
al tejado y descubrí que la casa de
nuestros vecinos también había sido
bombardeada en el centro de nablue se
congregaron multitudes para los
funerales de los tres hombres cuyos
cuerpos estaban envueltos en banderas
verdes de jamás el grupo militante
palestino afirmó que los tres muertos
eran miembros de su brazo armado y
confirmó que eran responsables del
atentado de abril Mientras tanto en un
tuit el Primer Ministro israelí Benjamin
netanyahu elogió a sus fuerzas de
seguridad nuestro mensaje a los que nos
hacen daño y a los que quieren hacernos
daño es tanto si tar un día una semana o
un mes pueden estar seguros de que
saldaremos cuentas con ustedes desde
principios de años se ha intensificado
la violencia entre Israel y los
palestinos más de cien palestinos han
sido asesinados a manos de las fuerzas
israelíes mientras que 19 realizan
perdido la vida en ataques palestinos